uh we asked uh people uh for some road
trip stories
and oh people sent in some what's up
what's up
what's up andrew my name is sean oh not
me university
andrew put it on a story house
representing that nola
a little bit of a road trip story for
y'all that i wanted to share
so a few years ago i moved back to
baltimore my hometown
from san francisco my boy rob drove with
me the entire way and we participated in
this thing called the kid rock
challenge so that meant that we listened
to nothing but kid rock the entire way
that sounds like some frat hazing right
there edm remix is a kid rock
hilarious classical covers the
sound instrumentals of kid rock
quartet she's doing kid rock jams
all i knew for a week driving cross
country was kid rock
we'd stop in different spots like we
stopped in arizona saw some lot lizards
had a few run-ins with a couple of them
new orleans throughout things means
paying for sex as well yeah
so just wanted to share that story with
you all right thank you guys for all the
stuff you're doing
your show is helping me get through this
coveted stuff keep doing what you're
doing
love the show gang gang buzz buzz buzz
buzz
gang buzz brother oh yeah brother
kid rock is my least favorite artist of
all time of all time
you don't like you know like my name is
king he's living a life and that's low
hair i've only heard like one song but i
just
i don't know maybe i'm wrong but i mean
you're a little younger so he might be a
little bit of a joke now he's like out
of shape still rocking the wife beat her
his hair yeah his hairs oh my god that's
not my guy
like no that's him that's not my guy
yeah bro you
you could almost do if you wigged up bro
you could go a little bit
i could see it kid rock's
[Music]
you know he has some [ __ ] jams does
he alright yeah you guys got to put me
on maybe i'm wrong well
let's take it easy well i used to cry at
the gym in one of his [ __ ] songs but
i was also on steroids and i i'm a
[ __ ] little bit about
a pandora ad if i had to
yeah dude of course i do a lot of [ __ ]
can you think of a worse artist to
listen to for a drive across the country
now that i think is fascinating i mean i
can definitely i could definitely think
of what you think because i'm a light
i'm i'm kind of a kid rock fan so yeah i
also like kids
but i respect your opinion yeah yeah
it's gonna wrong people yeah
but i think it's fascinating to think
that these dudes went full kid rock
across
it's just a hilarious artist to pick but
he has a lot like he has a large catalog
oh yeah you not like he has a ton you
guys are kid rock fans
but he's also defending him at a rate
that i can't really even respect at this
point i'm just saying you might not like
all this song
if you're gonna listen to so many is a
[ __ ] listen [ __ ] off featuring eminem
and then black chick white guy
that's your last hilarious album eminem
was not on the clean version gotta
respect eminem for that
i'm pussing and it's in the contract
also cowboy's dope too he has a mix
child he's got a beautiful little mixed
child though too
i know he does now he does cruises kid
rock cruises yeah
it's a nightmare you think you have all
bro fan base going to kid rock
cruise bikers that's great why don't you
chime in man well how about chen how
about chin who doesn't have to interject
constantly just be freaking yeah i'm
taking notes are you a kid rock fan chin
for sure chin's a musician that's why we
ask him yeah if you have to drive uh
across the country i would totally
listen to kid rock but if you have to
pick one artist who would you pick some
country [ __ ]
garth biscuit it would be country earth
brooks has a catalogue tim hall
tim mcgraw 100 i listened to a little
baby the whole time
you know what fed up slowed down i was
gonna say that i was gonna say
i would total my car so quick yeah i'd
just be too geeked up
yeah it's like it's a u-turn baby that's
all i listen to right now
i listen to sped up little baby you guys
know about nine five four fast music
no it's like some orlando bass they
speed up like um
basically trap music and they mix it all
crazy it's like the opposite of chopped
and screwed okay
oh the opposite of houston that's great
yeah wow it's like smothered and covered
kind of it's crazy
because you young bucks drink energy
drinks and like you want [ __ ] you
want it fast that's what we do yeah
yeah yeah we're like just we're like
looking for anything that's not cocaine
but we're like oh this caffeine drink is
300 milligrams yeah that's normal
yeah i'm hip i'm cool that's what i like
i'm still cold brew for life though
yeah yeah this is a four shot uh america
four shots see i can get behind that
that's great and it doesn't
does four shots why you told me to get
you what i get
i said get me an iced coffee cold coffee
that's a quad shot bro bro i said get a
cool coffee iced coffee man kept saying
cold
all right you guys ever overdosed on
caffeine before oh yeah is that
yeah i have a business i have a new
business partner actually we're
developing an app and he overdosed on
caffeine
so no dose pills you know those caffeine
they [ __ ] you up let me tell you this so
my buddy
you get all the dates in our school
right and i was this kind of ugly friend
that would just ride with him right now
he's a fat ugly chick
huh i wasn't fat i was lean you know
what i mean though
i think it was just lack of confidence i
probably i've always been kind of
it's a number of things if i brush my
teeth i'm an eight right so
but i always just had no confidence but
i would ride with him he was my best
friend so he would let me ride he'd let
me ride in the trunk even if he was on a
date and stay in the trunk
pop out the key things you could breathe
and uh
so one time he's going to pick up this
girl mary beth was her name dude and she
was hiding before i was like dude let's
get some noodles let's party a little
before your date dude we're [ __ ]
alive so we stop at the gas station do
we
eat a package right dude package of
of no doubt it was like these pills it
was like 30 shots of coffee
yeah it was all so sick
yeah bro you don't get sick bro so we
pull up at our house
he's like man i'm not feeling so great
let's just wait a minute before we go in
bro an hour and a half later he and i
are both have our seats
all the way back he's not even gone up
to the door this before cell phones
there's a moment where i saw her on the
porch like looking for him
we're laying in the car though and each
of us
are talking about how we can feel our
hair growing
and then we would take turns feeling
each other's hair
and bro by the time we kind of came
around to functionality
it was like 12 30 and uh the date was
there was no chance for him to go there
oh it was a wrap
you [ __ ] with those all the time i i
haven't but i just know that if you were
to overdose on caffeine that would be
the
fastest way yeah i don't want that you
got to go in you got to go hard